what's up everybody my name is mark and
deal and i am one of the creators of yes
theory and today we are on the 39th ever
episode of
the iced coffee hour and so far the show
has made over
36 thousand dollars so that was amazing
that was
thank you guys for having me thank you
this is a trip like there are very few
people that i meet that like i can't
believe you're here
that you exist because i've been
watching yes theory
pre-a million like i remember when you
guys did your million subscriber video
like this big celebration
and i was so pumped for you back then
like before i was even making youtube
videos so it's crazy to go from that
and like be sitting here with you man
why don't you talk about this stuff it's
crazy
likewise we've been a fan of your stuff
for you know for uh for a long time now
and after weeks now before no well once
again this disclaimer
i am like it's uh there was a joke made
before i
came because i was telling matt that i
was coming on your show
and it's uh for like the guy who cares
the least about
finance and about money on the team to
be the one
actually sitting here with you is quite
it's quite the joke for me we gotta talk
about that
yeah you were warning me you were like
yeah now it's time like i'm gonna get my
finances yeah
we're gonna do this 2021 is the return
around i mean it is it is truly one of
my biggest discomforts and i think it's
uh
today i was analyzing whether it's you
know
if it's just a matter of not liking
money or not being
finance oriented because i feel i have
the luxury of being in a team where
it's very much up matt's alley he likes
managing our money making investments
and
like doing all that so i felt i feel
like i can just kind of
not worry about it and focus on the
parts that i'm good at but but
this year i just realized that i feel
behind on my own financial literacy and
understanding how things work like every
day just talking to you know cliff
tells me more about ways to optimize my
financial situation being a startup
founder and being
someone who lives in america you know an
immigrant so there is definitely a lot
that are missing and i
i'm starting to believe that it's no
longer just the excuse of
being like oh i don't care about finance
i'm actually probably scared of finances
that's why i haven't
yeah pursued any kind of
like seeking awareness seeking knowledge
in it this is not such a scary thing
yes you know a little bit it's not such
a scary thing this is an intervention
that's what this is that's what this
really is we very much knew you have
your parents in the back
oh man we're gonna have to sit down and
talk about this let's
just go all the way back uh well first
of all we should say i
i owe this all to jack that's true jack
ran into you in venice
he did i was playing i was mid uh uh
paddle tennis uh game on the beach
and and jack walked by i was like mitt
serving and then and then he said
something he's like
oh like ground bro
it was not the most comfortable
experience for me right like i saw
someone i recognized from like youtube
and i was like
should i say hello should i say
something and i called graham before i
went up to you and i was like
graham like i see a marvel that was
early wow you're up i was like i was
like
should i say something to him like
what's going on he's like he's like yeah
man you gotta ask him
he's trying to like hype him up he's
trying to hide me up and i'm thinking to
myself like
like oh their whole channel is about
like seeking discomfort like i feel like
i should i should just go for it and so
i decided i was like all right i'm gonna
ask him
i know what to do i was like totally
like called out graham's name i was like
graham you know personal finance videos
i think he talks to thomas or something
yeah yes theory and thomas had told me
so that's
that's when i connected yeah so then and
then you're like oh yeah tell them to dm
me and then i guess we're here now
so interestingly enough yeah we just ran
into each other serendipity
yeah we are yeah so so explain this yes
theory from the very be i know you've
said this a bajillion times now
but for anybody who doesn't know you or
hasn't heard the backstory
how did you get started doing this and
by the way your channel is inspired i
think millions of people that
seek discomfort i like the documentaries
that you've made that thank you
iceman thing it's so cool like anyway
thank you so much so i'll take you back
to 2015
uh when i was a sophomore in at
university in canada
um i well i guess maybe let's take it 10
years back let's take it to 2010.
and that i was 15 at the time uh made
the decision that i was going to pursue
my education abroad because i got an
opportunity
a scholarship to go to a boarding school
in south africa
and the purpose of the school was to
bring together
the next generation of african leaders
people who wanted to solve different
problems
uh in on the continent and
my personal interest was more in tech
social media
and so that was 2010 i left egypt when i
was 15
in 2011 a few months in the egyptian
revolution happens the arab spring which
is actually
right now uh it's january 25th to
february
11th was was when it took place so we're
like we're in the anniversary the 10th
anniversary of that happening so 10
years ago
this took place and that was a
transformational moment for me where i
realized that
i want to work and create in this
intersection of technology and
storytelling
because i saw how much it impacted the
narrative in egypt and how young people
were able to use
you know the tools that are available
today facebook and twitter back at the
time
uh to actually mobilize people and to
bring people out on the street and i and
i just
the power of the tools that we have in
the power of the internet like
manifested in the most powerful way
i'd ever experienced and that was really
impactful for me so
i decided that after high school i want
to take a gap year because
i wanted to see if maybe there's a path
where i don't go to university and go
back to egypt right away
start working in tech build something
and contribute my part into like the
revolution this new wave of
for the country but you know very
quickly in 2013 which is when i did my
gap year after graduating high school
i this is that was the time egypt kind
of crashed politically
and uh i decided to do a gap here and
then after the gap here i decided to go
to university in canada
the gap here was in san francisco lived
there for a year and then did
two years in canada at university where
i studied cyber politics cyber politics
and cyber sociology
and i was the my school didn't have
majors they had questions
and my question at school was who
controls cyberspace
which actually is very relevant to
what's happening today of course
which i i'm very excited to talk to you
about yeah um but back to
back to the yes exactly exactly
back to the s3 narrative uh i'm giving
you the background because it brings me
to montreal in the summer of 2015
sophomore in university
had this idea for a tech startup that i
was building uh went to montreal to
raise venture capital
uh 19 years old just not knowing what
the hell i'm doing
and mid that journey i end up sneaking
into a party
at a rooftop and where like the students
live in
montreal which is uh they have mcgill
and concordia they're big to
universities
and i just showed up on this rooftop
started talking to people
and the more i talk to people the more
people pointed at thomas
being like you should talk to this guy
you guys sound very similar
and um 20 minutes later into being at
the party i
ran into thomas we talked there's this
instant like chemistry there was this
click that was just right there and we
started it just felt like we've known
each other for a very long time
and the following day we met for coffee
just started talking more he was tipsy
at the time so
you know it was just like in the but the
following day was actually when we
started talking about our aspirations
what we wanted to build
he was graduating university i was still
in my second year so
um there was a lot of synergies there
and he told me that
he had been making comedy skits on
youtube but he
it wasn't really his calling but he felt
like his calling is still
in creation on youtube but he really
wanted to figure out what
what the thing was and he told me about
his idea to do
uh 30 things he'd never done before in
30 days and tell a story about it every
single day
project 30 and at the time he had just
met this other guy
matt who also went to the same
university they worked on a marketing
uh project together and he ended up
bringing me uh
in to meet matt and that was just like
that was it
i met matt and it felt like the three of
us were just like unstoppable when we
were in the same room
just right off the right off the bat the
first conversation
the level of like vision and dreaming
and and this desire to truly live
a different take a different path than
what the conventional one that was set
for us and
the one that society just tells us to go
down finish university go work for the
big company you know have a
secure job yada yada um and at that
point we just had this
moment where for the next month we're
gonna quit everything we're doing and
we're gonna fully commit to this
and so we did and after a month we
looked at each other we
saw that this was the deepest connection
the three of us have ever developed
and that was like the closest each of us
have ever gone to anyone
and we start to realize that there is
such
an immense power to discomfort and to
the idea of
consistently getting out of your comfort
zone together and being able to do that
in the context of community
and actually the fact that by doing that
you're able to create community and have
the strongest bond that you can possibly
have
amongst you which is again this memory
or accomplishment of doing something
that you did not think that was possible
and for us
at that moment is just like we're all in
our early 20s
not knowing you know what life is
holding for us but at that moment our
like our moment was we're gonna be
together for this month we're gonna put
everything aside and we're gonna fully
focus on that
so as i said like after the month we
just uh it didn't take a lot of thinking
for us to decide that we need to double
down
further on this into this and and really
just see how we can take it to the next
level so
from that point onwards we all of us put
everything we were doing on the side i
didn't go back to school
put my startup on hold same with thomas
same with matt
and within four months we just fully
committed all our resources all our time
and uh in november of 2015 so we started
summer of 2015 in november
we got this very obscure email
uh being hey do you very informal hey do
you want to move to venice beach make
videos together have a house together
you're like what what is that i thought
it was someone trolling us
yeah got into it checked
and it was a real company it was
snapchat
out here in venice beach california
being like hey guys do you want to be
the face of this new channel that we're
doing and at the time we have 8 000
subscribers so there's it's not like
this shouldn't be an opportunity that
the channel 8 000 subscribers
gets but uh their thinking was the ethos
of what we were doing and the meaning
behind the why was so strong
that they just trusted that you know we
will adapt and
and by having by by them giving us the
exposure that snapchat would give us
at the time uh they kind of like
believed in yes theory and believed that
that could really
take things to the next level and it did
as we
you know as we start posting on on
snapchat in our first year after we
moved to la
uh that had like pretty good conversion
to youtube and gave us a good
launch pad for for the channel and then
after a year of doing that with snapchat
we just
decided to fully take the risk leave the
money and the security that they
provided and
and just do yesterday full time let me
ask you about
the snapchat so when they this the
snapchat when they reached out to you
how were they funding you were you
trying to split the channel did they say
we're going to give you a house in
venice
and just we retain ownership of
something or how how did this
come up see these are the kind of
questions that people don't really
people want to
ask the actual nitty gritty is over yeah
i don't know and then i have a story
don't forget me to tell you the story
okay
snapchat yeah but first do you know what
keeps me up at night graham
your lack of tinder matches nope it's
not that
your inability to get a girlfriend jeez
dude can you just please
no it's it's not that either it's that
tons of different businesses
and entities actually have my private
credit card information i mean
every single time we make any
transaction we are literally giving away
our credit card number luckily
privacy.com solves this problem so that
i will never have to deal with this
again let me break this down for you it
works like this instead of handing out
my credit card to everyone
i can link my credit card to one of
privacy's virtual cards i can then pay
for things using their card
instead of my own that's not even the
best part these privacy cards have
massive perks such as being able to
pause the card instantly
set transaction limits and cancel with
the click of a button this protects you
from ever having to worry about your
card ending up in the wrong hands
plus if you go with the privacy pro plan
you actually get one percent cash back
this is outside of any rewards you will
receive from your real card
oh my gosh one percent cash back people
are actually
making money with this plan the cash
back is super nice
do yourself a favor and sign up for
privacy.com there are literally so many
perks i cannot cover them all on top of
everything you will receive a five
dollar credit by clicking the link below
or heading to privacy.com
ich trust me you do not want to miss out
this is privacy.com
ich thank you so much privacy for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
so the way it worked is um
they actually invested in yes theory
so there was an a a stake into
they they just thought that the synergy
that was gonna be created by them giving
us the opportunity to be on snapchat
and the the quality of content that we
were gonna make for them
they thought it made sense that they
also allow us to post
this stuff on our youtube channel and
reap the benefits
because it would only be on on snapchat
for 48 hours 24 to 48 hours
and that's it it would never see the
light of day again so
you know we were able and again this
whole deal came
genuinely because they believed in yes
theory before they thought like oh this
thing will make us money
they just like so we were aligned
throughout
that um you know we were able to
create synergies and like making it a
win-win for both of us for
us to be here and not not just lose on
the value of creating all this content
for them but also be able to repurpose
it in person
on our youtube but for them to get and
also for them to get
a stake in yes theory at the time which
you know it was it was just an idea it
was nothing
but we end up yeah go on
but that story ends up that story ends
in 2019 when we buy back
our shares wow okay so now
can we go a little bit further and like
how much do they invest
because this is something i've wanted to
do for quite some time before even
making youtube videos i wanted to invest
in a youtube channel i wanted to pick a
creator at like you know 30 40 50 000
subscribe and be like you know what
i'm going to pay for you to be able to
quit your job focus on this full-time
but i want like
50 ownership it's got to be like a 50
no no so it was
it was 20 ownership okay and
it was about i have no idea if i'm
allowed to say any of this but i'm going
to say it anyways
it was a 50 000 in cash and throughout
the year
between four hundred to five hundred
thousand dollars in production value
wow so this is wait how many subs did
you have at this time we had like 10 000
subs yeah okay so back then for you i
mean looking back now i'm sure it's a
drop in the bucket but back then
they were taking a big gamble yeah
wow yeah so back then that was a
generous offer
anybody would jump at that and they
funded all of your adventures and was
like they were like the springboard to
like all the success yeah so do you
think there's a chance you wouldn't be
here today if it were not for that offer
no
no i think the biggest the reason i say
no is
the immigration piece that because
that's the one piece that no matter how
hard we worked or
how much how many hours we committed
that's the part that we were not gonna
get
past but actually not according to cliff
um
we uh we ended up uh
snatching end up facilitating the
process of getting bringing in
you know two out of the three of us were
immigrants
and for me you know thomas is french
swedish so right things a little easier
but
for me as an egyptian moving here having
dropped out of college
so it's not like there's a case for the
government to be like this guys
he has a youtube channel yeah yeah so
they were definitely instrumental to
just you know really
i think the other thing that that they
did for us is
there was no financial restriction on
our creativity right off the bat
any idea that we that we that we dreamed
we were able to make happen
uh and that really like made a lot of
made a big difference at the beginning
um
and and i feel like that's one of the
main reasons that yesterday has been
able to build such good momentum with
our ideas and how advanced like where we
think about
and flesh out each concept before we
create the story
uh i think it definitely came from just
having to do that wow at
such a deep level because we were
working with budget working with
traveling abroad and being not being
here in america filming for most of the
part when we were yeah
back then so everyone can understand
what exactly
like happened was that like yes or uh
that snapchat gave you funding
so you could post on snapchat stories
when they were trying to like
push their stories correct so again i
want to i want to correct because
it was a production wing that was with
snapchat it was like we were in dealing
with snap
it was vertical networks which was a
joint venture between snapchat and
uh elizabeth murdock big media investor
and they were operating out of venice
and they were building one of they built
one of the first studios for snapchat
to be able to make original content so
that's what the deal was with
and uh uh again one of
it wasn't ju like the mentorship element
and and the advising element it was so
big i mean we're just a bunch of dudes
just finishing college from canada
coming to la
this big town where you know so many
opportunities so many people want to
talk to us
so many agencies want to sign us we just
uh
it made a big difference at the
beginning to just have someone looking
out for us
wow and so yeah we there's definitely
there's a massive
like divine element to our story that i
truly believe in like i feel like at so
many points we're protected in ways that
were so
unusual uh even in having like you know
our mentor through this investment come
through and
and and be with us along the journey
throughout to give us the advice from
how to handle the whole thing wow here's
my snapchat story this is back
when i was uh i must have been 21 or 22
so this was back in like
2010 2011 2012 like between 2010 2013
uh i was doing a lot of leasing back
then so people would come to me as like
graham i want to
they would find me from craigslist and
they would say i want to rent a house
can you show me houses in this price
point and i probably get like 10 or 15
emails a day from different people
wanting to see leases
and i got an email from a group of like
three or four roommates saying that like
hey we want a house
in venice or beverly hills we're not
quite sure yet
uh we're all living together but can you
just show us all of these houses
and and usually i think like roommates
don't want to deal with roommates
because usually what ends up having you
waste a whole bunch of time
one of them doesn't like it and then
they all like we're like well
this guy doesn't so we're all going to
start looking over here and then what
ends up happening like
a month later they're like oh we just
each got our separate spot
so roommates rarely ever work out so i
asked
another agent to just show them around
and uh and i did that and i just
honestly i didn't follow up but they
would email me and say like hey we saw
this place come up and venice can you
show it to us
hey we saw this place and i just gave
him to another agent
didn't think anything of it and then i
run into that agent like
a few weeks later and he's like graham
those are really great clients you sent
me they're so cool
and i'm like what do you mean they're
they're roommates he's like
or i didn't say that but because i
didn't but i'm like oh yeah they are
and it's like yeah i know i i didn't
realize that they were they're
the starting snapchat or they or they're
they're setting up their business of
snapchat and venice
and it turned out then i looked back i
was like wait a second so i looked back
at them
and it turned out it was like four guys
like one of the original i don't know i
don't think it was evan but i think it
was this other guy in like three others
that they were living together in venice
looking to rent a house because they had
set up that spot on like ocean avenue
like right right yeah exactly but it was
that
when they were first starting up now all
of them are billionaires and then i saw
like a few years later they're all
buying these like five and six
million dollar spots in venice from that
but i just
didn't take it seriously in the
beginning so that was my snapchat story
awesome so yeah you know what next time
you think it's it's roommates maybe it's
co-founders
yeah that's a new yeah it's a big upside
here
you never know but uh that's incredible
that snapchat
invested in you so early on yeah and
then how did you start
just growing the channel from there like
what are some of the ideas that you used
in the beginning be like this is going
to go viral did you ever try to do that
or was it all
just organic also were they giving you
the advice on what you guys should do or
was it all just you guys
and then you just asked for funding for
each event and then they're like yeah
sure basically we would give them all
ideas of the things that we wanted and
then they were like we like that let's
do that
so they just picked from our roster of
ideas uh
what they thought would fit the platform
fit the demographic
fit the people that they want to talk to
um so yeah uh
so that was if they advised us or not
and your question was
um how did you start how do you start
growing the channel
i think the number one thing was to
fully commit full time
to not you know we were creating for
snapchat that was taking a lot of time
and obviously you know still making
taking these cuts and
doing it for youtube but still mentally
our main focus was
with our contract with our the
commitment that is paying for the
paying the bills so i feel like
yeah the biggest shift happened when we
decided that
this is the only thing we're go we're
doing and this is the year that we're
gonna hit a million subscribers
and we did and we did like it was truly
just that
um because there wasn't like a shift in
the kind of ideas that we're coming up
with or
i mean obviously we're always seeking
refinement and seeking
like evolution or ideas and never to get
stagnant with formats or just get stuck
in a
little youtube you know algorithm dark
hole of
of of these trends that people would
just like do and never stop
doing um so yeah it was just a matter of
uh giving it our full time and attention
and
early on you know algorithm rewards
consistency and
big volume of upload and at some point
we're able to reach
posting three times a week um wow yeah
i didn't i thought it was once a week no
we at some point we're doing
uh sundays thursdays and tuesdays
so like week sunday was the main video
thursday was
uh like a smaller adventure
and then tuesday was the house show
which is kind of like more vloggy
yeah what's happening around the house
but you know
part of us always thought that yesterday
the main youtube channel should not
be diluted with like vlogging or
showing things that are like subpar from
the regular yes theory concepts that
people are used to like
every story that you come to has to be
life-changing and that we kept that as
the
as the like the standard for what we
what we create isn't the problem how do
you keep
one-upping yourself because i imagine
you've i it's you've done some
crazy stuff but first do you like free
stuff that's because audible's giving
away
a free credit that can be used on any
book in their premium selection that
comes with their free trial with audible
you can download content and listen to
it offline so when i'm hiking in the
desert with no service i can still
listen to matthew mcconaughey's
biography and it's almost like he's
taking a walk with me if i'm having
trouble sleeping from editing the
podcast
all night long i can just turn on some
of audible's soothing sounds and fall
asleep right away if i'm getting ready
for a date i'll just turn on kevin hart
and learn some new jokes to tell you can
listen to audible when you're on the go
or when you're just doing chores i like
to listen when i'm cooking
cleaning or pretty much doing anything
that doesn't require my full attention
audible helps me maximize my time learn
new skills and gain a better
understanding of the things that i care
about audible has over 300 years of
audio content so there's something for
everyone no matter if you're trying to
learn new jokes for your next date or
wanting to learn how to build a million
dollar business
audible has something for you so if you
want to check that out visit audible.com
iced coffee or text iced coffee to
500-500 and as always if you're looking
for more information
check out the description thank you so
much audible for sponsoring this podcast
and back to the show how do you decide
like
i'm gonna one-up this there's got to be
a point eventually where you're just
like i'm
out of just i've conquered every fear
amount oh man
i mean we started this by talking like i
think one of my
biggest unconquered fears is you know my
own
relationship with money and finance so
maybe yeah maybe
on a on the outside it seems like well
at this point he's you know jumped off
all these things and did all these
stunts like what else is what
what other discomfort he's gonna see but
the reality is
you know the more the more you seek
discomfort the more
the more you discover like the depths
inside of you that you need to really
you know fill and and and oh my time to
shine
let's take some discomfort here start
spending money
that's almost uncomfortable yeah that's
uncomfortable for me is spending money
if you talk oh my god can we do an
episode with you i would love to spend
your money
graham would spend money physically and
spend my money i don't even
spend it though i was about to say like
if you told me like graham you have to
spend ten thousand dollars on rodeo
drive
i would be like in a panic i mean like
it's a waste of money
wow no well that's yeah i'm gonna
brainstorm i'm gonna bring some
something to
yeah i feel like i've been looking at uh
at this ford gt
and i i've been looking like every day
on ebay and like autotrader and just
all these sides of just like a 4g the
anxiety that i get just
looking at the price and just it's not
worth it but you know this isn't about
me this is about you today
why do you feel like you have so much
discomfort around money
was it it was it from your family it was
your family very much just doesn't talk
about money it's
is it i think because i left when i was
15 and i realized that it was a big
financial um commitment for my parents
even though i
i was on a pretty much a full
scholarship to go
but my dad had to pay some somewhere
between like three and four thousand
dollars a year
um which to put things in context that
was how much
my my
my education along with my siblings for
an entire year in egypt including all
material would cost
wow so all of a sudden like one kid was
just costing as much as
as much as all of them were costing
together so
um i lit i was very much
i didn't have any money in high school
and
uh that was very stressful because like
i felt like i couldn't do so much of
of like exploring and being out and
actually taking advantage of living in a
different country i was
very much on campus all the time and
and then when i like moved to san
francisco i lived
i lived with host families that were
very wealthy so it also felt like i
you know i was very much taken care of i
never had to worry about money in that
regard so
it went kind of from one extreme to the
other um
but still very much removed from needing
to worry about money and then
i end up going to university on a full
ride and they like i would get
monthly stipends so it kept almost the
decision to
to care about money or to deem it as
like an important thing to me kept
getting delayed
circumstantially and then obviously
started yesterday with matt and thomas
and
i was definitely not going to be the one
managing the money for the team you know
matt was taking care of that um and i
just stayed in my lane
creating just coming up with coming up
with ideas for
videos directing and um so it continues
yeah and now i think i convinced myself
that
it's the story that i don't really care
about money
but when in reality i know that
all my dreams probably are dependent on
me being in a
good financial standing to to drive
because i have such big dreams and you
know i'm definitely definitely gonna
need money to make that happen that's
gonna cost money yeah
i was trying to count like in the last
two years how many
last three years how many podcasts i've
done outside of our podcast yeah
and maybe there's two it's constantly
one of them wow
you know what quite a few people have
come to us be like we never do podcasts
but this is the one and i'm like what's
crazy that's why it's like uh people
always expect like oh i do
but it's i gotta get we get a lot of we
get a lot of requests but i just
i for some reason i don't feel compelled
so i i'm honored to be on here so cool
thank you yeah i'm happy to be having
the conversation thank you why do you
think you have this like inner drive to
to do all these like crazy things and to
be adventurous do you think that's just
like an
eight thing like it's it's just within
you
i i believe that
like our true power comes from our own
recognition
to the free child inside of each of us
and what that free child
truly desired and dr and dreamt and
wanted in in the world because it's very
much like the
the uncorrupted version of yourself
before society kind of puts it
on you um and i just always
i see the what you describe as the crazy
things like when i feel like the
the most like a free child like when i
do the sky like the extreme sports stuff
whether it's
skydiving club jumping or any of like
the high energy things that i do
it just like that puts me in a state
where i i feel connected to that
and i think this is where like to me
it's not i'm not like an adrenaline
junkie
it's almost to me that brings a
meditative state where i feel
more connected to myself than ever so i
i feel like
yeah you need to explain what you're
doing tomorrow through friday because i
was asking like hey
you want to do the podcast on tuesday
you're like no i i do oh
what am i doing yeah yeah so i am it's
actually a big deal so
i've been skydiving for two and a half
years and
one of the main one of them i have two
big goals in skydiving one is to do
uh a halo jump which i'm gonna get to in
a sec
second is uh to skydive over the
pyramids in egypt
uh in the next five years that sounds
expensive
yeah how much for permits to do that
oh well that's you see that's not at all
what i'm thinking about
well you can do it without permits but
then just don't get arrested yeah
yeah but i'm talking about the money
part of like i'm not thinking about you
you could do it without permits and put
yes siri
uncensored just on your stomach do a
vitality
get down you get arrested but it's
you're gonna call it
all the pr yeah so back to the halo yeah
halo it stands for high altitude low
opening so
for the military to avoid getting in the
radar zone when you're going vertically
that fast
you kind of you can really go undercover
past the radar
like water where a radar is detecting so
you're
you're flying at night like really high
you're getting out of the way
i'm not gonna do it at night oh wow
usually halos are done at night
um and then so you open that like you
jump at 25 to 30 thousand feet
which is really high up in the room yeah
that's like planes yeah
exactly and then you deploy at 3 000
thousand so you've got like twenty two
thousand where do you
normally deploy like ten thousand five
five
five is like safe three and a half is
usually one so but
so we're talking a difference of what
like five seconds every
every thousand feet of dropping is seven
seconds
wow is it normal skydiving like enough
for you
no like why i feel like you're with that
all your it's essentially the same thing
it's just like the free fall state right
closer to the ground going at the same
speed it's like i think
it's just the a matter of increasing
the my time no no my free fall time
imagine like i would be doubling my free
fall so instead of
falling for 50 seconds i'll be going for
like a minute 40 or a minute 50.
have you ever done one of those like
dome things where you can get inside and
they shoot air up at you and
like is that like the same thing so it's
actually one of the most effective ways
to train for
skydiving because you can you can
practice different body positions and
flipping mid-air and it's it's the same
thing
and you know in this case you can go in
the tunnel for 10 minutes and that
simulates 10 minutes of free fall which
is
10 jumps so in 10 minutes you can get
training that you
you would need 10 jumps to do that's
where like it gets really efficient
now here's the million dollar question
is insurance insurance
who insures you for this like any
insurance company would be like you know
what we don't want to cover that
that's why i don't go to them my
insurance is
my insurance is just and me running
safety properly and
really and understanding that my gear is
yeah i have health insurance that covers
extreme sports
but i mean to ensure they know you're
doing this no
[Laughter]
kaiser
uh what got me onto the insurance thing
was david blaine was talking about the
insane insurance like loops that he has
to jump through just to get insured and
they're on site a lot of these times
like with proper protocols but he's
doing these like
big extreme like just crazy stuff like
what was the one in a balloon that he
was doing
so he did a halo jump in a balloon so he
went up with the balloon to 25 and that
was it and he let go
but so actually you know this is um
we had to face that with the stunt with
will smith in 2018 yeah we we challenged
will smith to
helly to to bungee jump out of a
helicopter
and he ended up yeah and then he ended
up accepting the challenge you want to
do on his 50th birthday became this
huge youtube event is like the the live
event of the year on youtube
and that was the first time where we
realized that our youtube world and what
we
you know and what we do with our
production and how
just like very much guerrilla style run
and gun is so different from how
this town runs and like all these layers
of
permits and insurance and this and that
that in my mind i'm like well i mean it
makes sense because
will smith they have to he has to get
like that kind of insurance but
overall like for someone like david
blaine i also bet
he would be more than happy to do that
insurance but it's because that
he's a part of a bigger production that
has a legal team and has youtube's name
on it
like the more you and the more you yeah
you leave the realm of it being like
creating as an
independently the more you will start
needing to abide to the rules of the
game
that's very true so for me like i'm
doing this at my own risk i'm doing it
with
the best coach in the world um with the
best gear
so for me i'm like i'm not trying to
like
have someone pay all this money in case
i die you know like
i don't care about that because it adds
such a big layer of complication the way
we prep for these things that i'm not
i'd rather do with that that is true
that's the nice part about making
youtube videos is that you could just
walk down the street and film
and when they're filming like something
like selling sunset they have to give
notices to
every single storefront for like a week
or two
prior and then if you don't agree with
the notice you could
dispute it and then it could go through
like this this
weird so where it's like it's just with
the city and then back and forth and it
could delay it
months it's it's crazy and that's just
for like filming a scene
indoors but if you're going to be using
the parking lot or like
anything you got to notify everybody
versus like danny duncan can just go to
hollywood boulevard and just flip on a
camera and just
it's it's wild it is but i mean
i wonder where where is gonna be the the
breaking point
for like youtubers not being able to
allow to like
to just go down on the boardwalk and
film i don't think there is gonna be a
breaking point because when do you draw
the line between someone just like hey
i'm videotaping my mom at her first time
at the pier versus
no you have four million subscribers so
you got to pay a permit yeah they're
never gonna put some arbitrary like
over a million subs permit under a
million subs no permit
i don't think they're ever gonna get
like that so but it's once you get like
a production crew behind it then there
becomes this big like conglomerate that
you could sue
yeah like somebody trips on a wire
and then they they stub their toe and
that's like 20 million bucks to
cbs for doing that but really quick we
have a word from our sponsor
skillshare skillshare is the best
platform to use if you are a creative or
curious person looking to learn a new
skill they have
thousands of inspiring classes for all
kinds of people on topics ranging from
illustration and design to photography
editing and more so i'm actually in the
middle of a course from ali abdull
called
video editing with final cut pro 10 from
beginner to youtuber and i actually love
this course i've been finding it really
valuable all of the editing tips and
tricks that ali can provide and of
course i recognize that not all of you
are editors
skillshare is made for everyone there
are loads of other classes to take that
cover a
very wide range of topics skillshare is
also incredibly affordable especially
when compared to pricey in-person
classes
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month even if you don't have
anything specific in mind
i think it's always a great thing to be
continuously learning and trying out new
things and there isn't a better place to
be doing all of that than skillshare so
i strongly encourage you to check it out
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com iced coffee where our
listeners will get a free trial of
premium membership
i strongly encourage you guys to go
check it out at least go try out the
free trial trust me you're gonna love it
that's skillshare.com
iced coffee thank you so much skillshare
and back to the podcast
but just listening to you i would say i
i think
just from what i've gathered so far
you're very much a creative type and
that
i think leads the way not so much
financially but i think just
this the aspirations outweigh almost
anything else i don't think it's a bad
thing
uh most of my family i think is the same
way it's very much just creative
and when it comes to finances that's
just this this abstract thing that
they've never really thought about
before
so it makes sense i don't think it's a
bad thing at all i i could probably use
more creativity in my life besides the
thumbnails
well that's where yeah all right are you
going to rob my back of yours
yeah it's like you just love spending
money
but yeah you spend money or help you
save money or heights that's another
thing
heights i couldn't do couldn't do okay i
get so anxious over that
have you been skydiving before no i've
never worked all right ladies and
gentlemen we are doing this
live on the podcast and every ram is
going to be joining me skydiving next
week
since
we'll start with just a regular jump so
uh next week yeah make sure you
you comment and and uh if this video
gets how many
how many how many views did you get if
this is 25
if this video gets 10 000 likes uh
graham is definitely doing this with me
next week no not ten thousand like maybe
a hundred thousand likes
a hundred that ten thousand likes guys
what's the highest what's the most likes
you've gotten on a podcast
probably like twenty 20. okay if this
video gets 30 000 likes
grandma's going to be joining me and
he's going to be jumping i don't know 13
000 females
no yeah yeah absolutely yes i heard it
yeah
i'm coming i don't even go on podcasts
and i'm on your podcast
no i wouldn't do it wow i wouldn't do it
just why don't you do it
i don't want to do it what are you
trying to do no no i also i want the guy
who
doesn't want to do it more jack really
doesn't want to do it
we'll give this a try at the end i think
we could try it at the end i'm not gonna
i would say if if i got paid uh
a million dollars for me because no
[ __ ] way yeah that much yeah
i just wouldn't do it oh my god okay
well 30 000 likes right now please
and then and then and then if it gets 30
000 likes i'm gonna
show up to this house i
like it i like life too much like why do
something that would just
put me at risk a little bit more of
something happening just
a little bit more let's say there's a
one in a thousand chance
you see one in a thousand that is an
amazing segue to my next point because
we started talking about
uh skydiving and there's like this
funny saying yeah that we always say for
people who are scared
is that you're more likely to die in a
car accident than you're likely to die
skydiving and it's a statistic but
that's not because
people just don't skype so few people
want to do it
it's still true that's the point it's
still true
and i end up the when i so i had a
previous attempt where i was training
for the stunt and i was gonna do it in
september of
2020 and on august 28th on my way back
i end up getting in a deadly car
accident almost almost looked at me
right the car
flipped yeah didn't it yeah so that's uh
that's why i'm like you know you just
don't know
when you say like why do something that
increases that risk
you actually don't know if that moment
of skydiving will
you know significantly impact your
perspective about life and your
appreciation
for where you live or you know in
comparison for
whatever perceived risk that you're
thinking will at your gosh graham is not
falling for it i feel like he's the
exact
opposite of you like crazy lives in
comfort
his whole life is like what is the most
comfortable thing he can do
that is that is very true
we're working on i don't leave the house
rarely it's
the extent of me leaving the house is
like let's go pick up sushi from sushi
ipo because they have a good deal
because yeah it's cheap
that's good yeah mine is just
seek comfort that's that's graham's
motto you could just get a shirt that
says that that's me
you got a heated seat i'm gonna spend
your money and i'll take you skydiving
that's horrible i i like that being like
the takeaway of today
i'll spend grams money i like him i love
that
i i gotta say like like since you do so
many
uncomfortable things that's like your
thing do things still make you
uncomfortable
or is everything just like easy for you
now
um as i said it's like the more you seek
discomfort the more
you realize your own capacity for uh
like self-improvement right like it's
you're never gonna reach a point where
i'm like you know what i'm very happy
with where i'm with where i'm at i don't
want to improve anymore
and the process of improving is the
process of seeking discomfort so
it's like to say that i've gotten so
good at seeking discomfort
means that i never approach seeking
discomfort in the right way in the first
place
because it's it's it's never supposed to
run out
right there's always some something
there's always something in there yeah
but then again i'm sure that you're
getting
better at being comfortable like like
certain things for example like
last time i was at the grocery store i
forgot to get charcoal from my grill
and i was already in line and i was like
checking i was like can i go grab
something really quickly to the guy like
at the you know cash register it was
uncomfortable for me
like i i didn't like saying that because
there are people behind me waiting in
line and i'm like i gotta go get my
thing now that was really uncomfortable
like stuff like that
you know it's like the way i see it so
definitely i'm more
more comfortable like i'm very
comfortable now expressing myself
saying going up to anyone on the street
telling them whatever it is that i want
to tell them
so the next level of discomfort here is
to be able to use this comfort to maybe
step in situations where
someone else might might need it you
know someone stuck in a
situation where it's you know they i'm
seeing that they can't really express
themselves or
or get what they what they want so maybe
that's the moment where i use this extra
comfort that i have with situations like
this to step in and
be uncomfortable yeah and be
uncomfortable in a situation that it
doesn't that is not mine
so i always like this is the leveling up
that i see in
in this conference like well if i'm so
good at something then i should probably
use it to
benefit someone else um and in this
like if you follow that like philosophy
you'll never
it will never get to a point where
you're like oh yeah i'm good i shouldn't
seek any more discomfort
you're gonna write a book one day yeah i
do math is writing the book really
yeah math is writing the book so end of
2021 that's when the first
yes theory book is gonna be out and he's
definitely the better writer
is it gonna have pictures in it i think
so is it gonna be a picture it's gonna
be a cartoon yeah it's gonna be a comic
strip
oh man we have i have like a thousand
polaroids from
our past five years i'm like big on
polaroids i'm big on like
keeping i didn't photos yeah i didn't
realize what it takes to be a new york
times best seller is just ten thousand
yeah
yeah so like dude anybody yeah anybody
well not anybody could be a new tech but
i feel like if that's
achievable just to sell ten thousand
comments if you just put the price
super super low yes everybody buys it
like a dollar
yeah five dollars an e download whatever
so there is
it's a little tricky because you have to
go to be
like the way they submit the list yeah
it has to be physical yeah there's like
a few
very yeah sell it seven bucks that's
break even yeah hardcover's got to be
like 12.
sure you could do but yeah there's uh
uh there's people who like back engine
like reverse engineer the process of
like being top of a category on amazon
and they can tell you exactly how much
money
it will require how many copies like
they give you the full breakdown of
how much you need to pay to get to like
the number one and how much
and what the return will be i wonder if
there's a way to game this where i could
be like guys i'm coming out with my book
it's one page long and just it's gonna
be like
five bucks i'll lose money on it but
then i could call myself a new york
times bestseller maybe you open the book
and it's just like
smash like button or just like some some
one little word that's the end of the
book
you know something this is like a very
yes theory idea but you know
writing a book in 24 hours and making it
a new york bestseller
if it's gonna be a page like oh wow come
up with like what is you know the 20
pages of
that you can write in a day okay that
would be terrible because it's i i feel
like the pressure
it would be an essay if you want to have
to get done in 24 hours
that would be a lot of fun have you
thought about doing that so
i mean it's we're brainstorming now what
ideas can help with the launch of the
book when
when matt is ready um i mean he's going
to take nine months to write it so it's
definitely not going to be 24 hours but
a week i feel like a week a week yeah a
week sounds good a week does sound like
this way it can actually be a book
rather than an essay
you should you should really think about
it that would be interesting that's
something i would do in comfort though
at home yeah i would totally do i think
that would be amazing to be able to do
that one week
to be a new york times bestseller and
i'm sure i'm sure people would love to
have just like your knowledge
synthesized and booked for that would be
cool
yeah i might do that go i'll go ahead
okay
i'll do that i'll be in new york times
vessel
okay fine i'll do it i just i find it
amazing because like
a lot of our guests i feel like
sometimes it could be a little
uncomfortable coming on to like
somebody's podcast especially if it's
about finance where we like grill them
about their finances
but like look at you man you're like
sitting back oh yeah
you're the most laid so comfortable
right i want to hold the mic in my hair
legs are like crisscross applesauce just
yeah it's awesome okay so now let's
let's make you uncomfortable here let's
talk about the finances of yes theory
can you talk about that or how much how
much can we talk about or we just talk
about you
i'm just curious you see i i would have
i don't know
i don't know of the finances of yes
theory because we're in this like
transitional
moment for us as a company so i don't
know how much i
uh but i mean like we can talk like
let's talk about you yeah so i'm
guessing what what happens is yes theory
is a company that's owned by all of you
and then you pull a salary from that i'm
guessing right that's correct
okay can we talk about what what what
salary
you've decided to take in there and also
how much did you
buy back your portion from snapchat oh
we're getting there we're getting there
man we're getting there
so i can't disclose that but we got a
hell of a good deal
like like why did they go out on such a
limb for you yeah
like we we really as i said that's what
when i say like there's this divinity in
our story like
okay to even see that investors you know
give giving us back our shares knowing
that they could definitely get more but
out of just like the good in them and
not wanting to drain yesterday out of
cash
they truly just honored that that was
that was incredible yeah
and uh and again it's like a testimony
for
creating with purpose and when you know
your purpose is at the center of what
you do
even in situations where that's nev what
that should never happen like
there's a finance guy there in that room
that is not supposed to left
a penny on the table you know un
unutilized but for us like there's this
like they just
fully understood that you know we
shouldn't these guys are
just starting their career and they have
big plans for what they want to do with
the company so
let's not drain them out of the cash
that's good yeah so
good on snapchat good guy snapchat yeah
shout out to vertical networks
yeah and then how how easy they made
that um
for yeah there we do have we do take
salaries
uh man i i have no we've never ever
talked about numbers so i don't even
like inter for the team i don't even
want
like know what their expectation for
like what are we
what we're supposed to share like we've
never talked about this because
i don't want to put you on the spot
whatever you don't want to make you
uncomfortable here yeah
well i i'm i'm okay with it honestly
whatever you're comfortable talking
about and
it serves a problem i mean we're gonna
we're gonna go from that but then we're
gonna deviate into like exactly where it
breaks down and
and how to improve that yeah if you want
to share numbers
i'd say yeah i i i'll keep it as like
undisclosed okay yeah so the way it
works is we take a salary
uh not nothing too crazy can we keeping
that low
and then at the end of the year since
we're shareholders in the business we
get distributions and
again we very much keep
most of it in the business because we
want to reinvest uh but we make sure
that
i mean for the first three years we were
not paying ourselves so the whole thing
it's like a thing off the past two years
is when we actually start building
uh like having liquid in our bank before
that
it was just like we were living off the
business and you know business covering
travel
expenses transportation house
all all these things and we were just
like happy putting all the money back in
that makes sense too i i would agree
with that and i would imagine
i see i don't know if the the overhead
has to be high because i've seen
that crazy nice plate don't you have two
places
we have we have we have our apartments
like which is where we live
yeah uh and then we have the yes house
yes house yes
that looks so cool with you you got the
aquarium in there you got the multi
levels i saw that place i'm like i think
you got to come visit perfect i want to
i want it i want to go visit it
come on yeah i would love to um
but yeah i mean if so for that because
we didn't get
like an office office this is a live
work for like artists and living
uh it's not as crazy expensive as you
think
for you know a full company where you've
got seven employees so we pay
7 200 a month for that and it's on it's
nice
it's a nice spot abbott kenny prime
location very very
very much prime location and um you know
compared to other commercial spaces that
i was touring
before we made the decision on that
which was like i think the minimum was
12 yeah
in venice at the time so we're a lot
lower and we're able and that
you know gave us leeway to be able to i
was i fully designed the place and
customized it worked
with artists and architect best friend
on on setting it up so it definitely
gave us
leeway to be able to spend more on
making it feel like our
space commercial real estate is so
behind on this there's so many people
now that are renting houses
instead of renting an office because a
house is nicer
and it's way less money you get the same
thing for half the cost
it's incredible yeah especially in the
current landscape of
of how people are running their
companies being like that
mix of like remote and on-site yeah a
lot of like we i was just visiting a
friend yesterday who
gave up his 40 000 uh dollars a month
lease
on lincoln to get uh for a commercial
space
to get this amazing house in in mar
vista that has
great pool a hot probably like 18. wow
really holy [ __ ] all right spot off the
real estate agent
yeah man i know i know how much there's
more vista places
no because i figure it's a new
construction i know they all did they're
just cookie cutter plate but
yeah they all rent for 18. wow spot on
um so yeah we uh that that helped a lot
with just like
being able to make the decision on on
optimizing for space early on okay
so where's the money going yeah your own
personal expenses yes because i'm sure a
lot of your sp
like expenditures are just like business
expenses because you said like right
food when you're working and stuff like
that like what is my biggest expense
clothes i i don't i don't get yeah food
maybe like
but i'm also not like i don't go to
fancy restaurants i'm just when i
if i'm gonna like i i just it's like the
basics i don't really spend on anything
i mean my biggest my biggest cost so far
is
i'm investing in uh
a foreign country's economy to get their
passport
to be able that's interesting yeah what
countries same kits
250 120. 120. wow what's the advantage
doing that
the advantage of doing that is compared
to my egyptian passport that gives
that gets me into 54 country visa freeze
and it's the 54 countries that you've
never heard of
that you'll know that you probably
wouldn't want to visit so my passport is
pretty useless for travel
everywhere i go i need to apply for a
visa i need to show up in person i need
to show them that i
financially capable or won't break my
visa and like run away to their country
so it's it's just the most annoying
process
and it has prevented me from
participating in
fifty percent of travel videos for
yester wow
yeah so there's like a big part of
yesterday that i'm missing thomas is
in the process of he's going to
chernobyl in ukraine he's going to
mauritania to do like this crazy
train ride like all these and the most
amazing adventures
and the only reason i'm not
participating is because it's really
complicated
with my egyptian passport um and
you know i just thought at some point it
made sense i did the math and
and admits like that investment made
sense for my career and my own personal
just well-being and
uh being able to enjoy the opportunities
that i that i get so
the the senkids passport will allow me
to get into 154 countries visa-free
including the uk uh
schengen area so europe all of europe uh
russia like all these countries that you
know before it would be a nightmare
or you could just get married so
marriage was always something that you
know my immigration lawyer was bringing
up but
it's not as straightforward as people
think
it is and it's not as clean as as just
like oh yeah
let me just pay this person and get me
and i also just didn't
want this to be how i get a status in
okay you know i get that yeah like i
want i just wanted it to be i
like i know that i can do work that
that makes me deserve to be here okay
and i wanted to be through that
uh through that process and right now
the visa that i currently
hold in the us will transfer to a green
card in the next round
and then after that three years after
that i'll be able to get a passport to
the u.s
but because my egyptian passport expires
sooner than that timeline i needed to
figure out uh
a way to to go to get around it so saint
kitts
uh the the solution all right so where
is your money now going let's get back
to this where we're skirt where's my
question here
and what yeah what what do you want to
work on did you invest in the industry
i just like i was in an uber ride in
austin going to a friend's house and
then i was seeing all the
fuzz on on social media i was like ah
put 150.
it's my first i like i downloaded
robinhood in the uber right now
yeah yeah so i just like put 150 and i
finished dinner and i looked at my
account i was like
there's five hundred dollars in it wow
so with that right before the elon musk
tweet it must have
yeah beginner's luck right there that's
beginners every year yeah every beginner
gets one
win i did not i i sold to britta to put
to
get back the money that at the 150 and i
left the rest
yeah yeah so now it's just like the
money is all done yeah
so where else are you investing or how
do you want to oh actually
yeah i'll i'll tell you that i mean my
biggest
investment in 2020 was uh speechify
which is cliff's company so i'm more
focused on
uh investing my money into projects that
i can
engage with and and and uh you know so
far i've
done four investments
uh tanzoti uh which is a matcha company
uh our friends started a few years ago
okay liquid iv
which just exited with the unilever
they sent us some some stuff did they
nice yes yeah great
uh wait so you exited that position no
no
the company exited after we invested so
without that like it was a buyout it was
yeah they got acquired which you were
able to pull out your money
yeah i mean the money made its return so
that's like yeah that was our first
successor
that was our first success can you just
tell us the roi on that it was like a
10x or
50x it was like we invested in the last
round and it was three
three four x okay yeah last round yeah
early rounds would be early rounds would
be
yeah that's what you want man wow
that's all my investments speechifies
for it's for all those exes okay and
you're
yes and that's like you know i was
actually telling thomas like it
i hate the idea that and i know you're
gonna you're gonna really agree with me
on that
but like putting on in all these like
retirement funds and all these
like i hate the idea of putting money to
just sit like that i don't care how much
it's making i don't
i don't care about the compound and all
that i just feel like
i'm a lot happier to just be putting
this money in a young entrepreneur that
is
just like doing actually something
because at the end of the day i
i don't think my wealth is going to come
from whatever i put on
the side for my you know for my separate
ira or anything
with that attitude i know i know i know
that's why i'm here i think i think
you're doing enough
and you're living frugally enough where
putting fifty thousand dollars a year
into the stock market and a boring
retirement fund
is not going to change your life it's
not gonna do it it's you're not gonna
notice any different you could still do
all the other
investments you want you could live
exactly the same except you could put 50
000
a year like 5 000 a month into the s p
500
that's it and here's the benefit here's
how i could spin this around for you
think of it this way you will grow your
money consistently so that when you
find a really good deal and you find a
startup and an investor that like you
really believe in
you have all this money sitting on the
sidelines so you could be like all right
i'm going to use that money and i'm
going to invest in this really good
opportunity
or you just leave it there so you think
of it that way yeah
yeah are you just like sitting on a
bunch of cash in your bank account yeah
no
don't tell me it's in it it better not
be is it a high interest
it's in a checking account no can i is
it is it over six figures in a checking
account
yes oh wait six figures is over a
hundred thousand yeah
no come on no no
yeah um okay yeah okay well first of all
i'm going to tell you immediately what
you should do tonight
is sign up for ally bank okay so it's an
online bank
totally free ally bank ally bank now i
could pitch
depends on what you want to do i could
pitch uh yada bank which is the company
that i invested in that was
that was my first startup investment
ever was yada bank
it's a savings account that rewards you
for every 25 dollars you save
you get one entry to be able to win a
prize anywhere from like 10.
yeah 10 cents up to like 10 million
bucks some guy won 40 grand
some guy i i forget is it mark or
something like that i can't believe it
uh that that's been the top prize ever
paid out by yatta bank so far wow so if
you want to do that
the the interest rate on that right now
works out to be about
one point eight to two percent but
that's spread across a year for all
prizes
uh or ally bank is just a guaranteed i
think it's point
five or point six percent they're a
great online bank if you wanna use them
for like checking and stuff like that
that's what i would recommend
yata bank is just a savings so if you
knew like next month or two you're not
going to use that money you want the
best return yada bank
if you want like a bank account you
think hey maybe next week i'm going to
use the money i want all of it
and a customer service line i could call
them up then do allie bank okay
well that's that's really great so yeah
so that's what i would do and then at
the very least you're gonna get
half a percent in interest which is not
much at all but it's better than getting
nothing yeah
you know what actually would make this
worse if you said the bank was wells
fargo
no it's chase okay okay good i have
chase yeah
chase is decent but yeah you got to get
the money out of there okay because your
money is think of it if you've kept that
money let's just say you've kept a
hundred thousand
in a checking account over the last year
really what you're missing out on
you've just sacrificed twenty thousand
dollars in profit
by just keeping your money out of the
market for the last year
twenty percent 20 years losing money wow
and you're losing well well you could
say that for the 20 return on the market
too
is subject to inflation but i would just
say just cancel that out
20 grand is how much you've just left on
the table by
not making a decision on that just
keeping it cash now we're all guilty of
it we all have uninvested money and
there's a chance the market could have
gone down in which case you know good on
you for keeping the money in cash but
overall
you're gonna have more gainers than
losers yeah and overall i think it'd be
pretty safe to say
you're leaving about seven to nine
thousand dollars a table on the table
every year for every hundred thousand
dollars you're just leaving in there
well time to change that yeah evidently
yeah and 20 grand think of it this way
too like this would because i think
as long as we could we could relate this
back to what you want to do which is
investing in entrepreneurs
that's an extra 10 grand right there
that you could be investing back for
every 100 000 so just think of it
i'm investing my money so that i have
more left over that i can invest in
these other things i'm really passionate
about but
in the meantime i may as well be doing
this boring stuff because it just it
pays the bills
have you have you thought of starting a
like a fund
no never want to do that really no
because youtube is is where i think my
strength is
and i don't want to deviate my time
because i know like in order for me to
do something well and for a startup
that's got to be 24 7. yeah
and i can't do youtube and that i feel
like youtube is is like the machine
and i want to be involved in startups
that i would be able to
work on just as an ideas person and then
create content around that like yada
bank was something that
i yana never asked for a video by the
way at all
but i purposely invested in yada bank
because i love them
but also because i knew that like i'd be
able to make such a fun video with this
and like is my first angel investment i
could explain why i invested in them i
could talk about the company
and then i was thinking well you know
i'll make some of my money back
just even if the investment flops the
video itself is going to be really good
and it's like another idea to get a
video out there i see so like i want to
do more like that and if i
was your first investment as a first
angel investor okay not a first ever
investor yeah
first ever angel investment have you
invested in startups before
yeah before this okay never before that
was the first one and then i had two
others
right after that that we'll just see how
they do oh man um
maybe maybe i'll i'll get you excited
about investing in entrepreneurs
investing
and you can you can you can get me
excited about saving my money yeah well
what i've really wanted to do and this
is going to happen
at the las vegas place but what i want
to do is basically do a shark tank sort
of deal where i could get like me and
the buddies together
and we'll just invite people on the show
just to pitch their ideas
and we'll just see if we want to invest
in them or invest in their idea
yeah and i would but it's tough because
i don't want to just copy shark tank so
we've
been like developing something in that
direction really
and yeah so maybe there's an opportunity
there to i would love to be a shark on
that yeah
yeah something like that yeah but yeah
that's what i wanted to do and we've
come up with a few ideas just on the
back end of like i want to bring 10
entrepreneurs to the house and have them
like duel it out over like who gets an
investment just
stuff like that i wanted to start going
in that direction i think would be a lot
of fun
i i'm uh i'm down i'm definitely
into it all right i want to make it
happen oh yeah i'd be
i'd be good with that i'll tell you one
of my ideas after after filming but i
was telling jack this but uh yeah
if you would want to travel to vegas for
this we'd probably do it in like a few
months
but i think it'd be a really fun concept
you could be one of the judges i think
would be
really cool we'll definitely yeah let's
make it happen
and just the over like the investment
space as i said matt has been
very much focused on
how we can like allocate our money to go
towards investment because
you know with the s theory it's not just
like it's not just the money that comes
it's actually the main thing that comes
is the distribution power and the
access the community and we feel like
there's just an opportunity for like a
creator's fund
and being able to like pull together a
bunch of creators that
very much aligned and and can together
make
some really great decisions on things to
invest in that would
have like really a high return so would
love to
you know bring into that conversation
and see if there's yeah yeah go off
synergy
that's what i'm realizing too i think
the the big thing with youtube is that
uh i think initially you see that like
oh i could sell
merch or i could i could get ad revenue
or i could come out with a program
but really like when you get down to it
it's marketing yeah
like big brands for for what you would
make a video on
a brand might pay like 500 dollars just
to get
to the eyeballs that you were able to do
organically for free
and that's what i'm starting to realize
it's like you're able to drive so much
traffic and attention to
places where ordinarily they would never
have that reach your cpm for the main
youtube channel must be
yeah wow like what is it at uh
25 30 something yeah at the peak i think
was almost 40 it was like 38
that was december this last december was
like 38 bucks wow
that's like compared to four to five
for us you get 45 cpm yeah that sounds
like you're hardly pm is like two
to two and a half it's too low yeah i
don't get it see that that's what
doesn't make sense
maybe put like an ad or two per video
like we
yeah there's pre-roll uh pre-roll in uh
post-roll
but yeah we do uh we do mid-roll for
longer videos yeah
you got to do mid-roll on every video
yeah
really okay because what i've noticed
too is that mid rolls
um help the algorithm i think the
algorithm just knows that this video is
performing well
it's making more money for youtube
advertisers are happy
that they get uh they get more exposure
and because of that and this isn't
proven
i just think the videos do better and my
experience has always been
that videos that are heavily monetized
heavily monetized lots of ads
heavily monetized tend to do better for
the algorithm so anytime people are
upset
i mean for throwing in mid rolls it's
just like if you want to grow
and you want to help youtube out you
want to help me out
just understand it's a part of the
process you throw mid wheels out
in the video it does better in the
algorithm youtube pushes it to a brand
new audience who could get the same
message
i think it's a win-win for everybody and
it's better than watching tv commercial
people have gotten so spoiled now
over like oh i have to watch five
seconds a day do you remember when you
used to watch like spongebob
and like at the peak the peak moment
three minutes
you would have enough time to go and
like microwave uh like a hot pocket
yeah and come back and like you're still
going through commercials that's what it
used to be like we have it so easy right
now we really do
for free information but anyway but yeah
i'm i'm open to that idea
um but that that's my advice to you is
50k a year
i think that's doable you'd be able to
do it 50k
put that aside and everything else could
be your fun money but i think as long as
you have just that foundation of 50k
consistently you'd be set because no
matter what happens
you're always going to have that to fall
back on and you could be set for life
you just got to do that for like
10 15 years 50 50 50 50 keep keep it
going you'll never have to work after
that if you didn't want to just don't do
it in robin hood
do it in like a different brokerage okay
yeah okay yeah i mean i will accuse that
i i don't i mean i know i'm gonna get
haver i don't i don't mind robin hood
i i don't mind maybe maybe i
know there's gonna be a cancel leave it
in there yeah um
i think they're the easiest brokerage
just to point at like a finger rat and
be like you're
bad a lot of brokerages had issues robin
hood i think is is the poster child of
issues because they've grown the fastest
they're the
newest most disruptive brokerage out
there and i think
there's a lot of growing pains they
didn't do everything right but you know
but if you're doing buy and hold where
you're not even checking the app every
day you're checking it like i wouldn't
do it
where you're contributing like 50
dollars one time and yeah
then just yeah mike personal belief
is that anything over like 200 grand
it's probably best
to go with a big brokerage like fidelity
or
charles schwab most likely a vanguard
they're all great we're with vanguard
vanguard's fin it's fantastic yeah so
any company that you could physically
just pick up the phone and call someone
for me over like 200 grand that that's
the amount under like you know
under then then it's like if you play it
doesn't matter i was going to be like oh
well i actually put
56 000 in the separate ira this year but
it wasn't my idea and i would have never
done it if i wasn't like if thomas and
matt were like
you just do it just don't i'm so glad
you did that yeah yes i'm so glad you
need to be doing that every year and
they're like
listen it's just don't even think about
it it's going to save you money
just trust us and i was like well what
if i just i literally said that i was
like i don't want to say
i just want to use this money i'm going
to take it i'm invested in five startups
i don't want to i don't want to put this
and they were like well do both
yeah just like dumb about it so you're
you're making enough where you could do
both and it's not like your day-to-day
lifestyle does not sound expensive it's
not like you're bawling at clubs and
stuff like that
so you have so much money left over i
don't drink alcohol huge
if you want a pepper i've never been
drunk in my life really
yeah wow it's like the biggest money
saver see i stopped i stopped drinking
for the most part i will have the
occasional drink
and i limit it to one and it's usually
not more than like once a month and it's
rare
like that's a celebratory thing or it's
just like one drink
if that i cause it's just i hate the way
it makes you feel the next day yeah
that's that too
yeah um but yeah that's
uh so yeah i mean give that your main
advice is to put 50 aside i guess
thank you thank you matt thank you
thomas yeah appreciate the they're
honest
yeah i would agree what else what what
other financial questions you have for
us
oh wow getting a free consulting session
free consulting um
what has been your smartest financial
decision
that you've made in your life we're
asking questions like that now huh
game stop smartest financial decision
youtube channel
no no i would say the smartest financial
decision was
probably investing in real estate and
and living no i would say
is living below my means living so
extreme for so long
i would say it really was not until
about a year it was a year ago when i
started like
spending money a year ago and even then
it's
it's not been like frivolous stuff but a
year ago
i wasn't even in here i was in an 800
square foot duplex it was a one bedroom
one bathroom
um worked from the garage and i had kept
that up i mean i was
i was doing even over a million dollars
a year still living in that same
800 square foot duplex in mid-city like
this
i don't want to say it was like a bad
area but like when you think of
the income you you don't think of like
mid-city l.a
um and uh yeah and i just
didn't spend any money and that was the
best financial decision
ever this this house was the first time
i had ever done something for myself was
this house
and i could justify that it that it made
itself back because i was able to do so
much better work
yeah from this house in the backyard and
just being in a better environment i got
more creative did you buy this house
yeah
okay and and then the las vegas place
was
it was i think a fantastic decision just
when you look just
at all the benefits of living in las
vegas and no traffic and just all the
connections and all the friends there
and everything else
it just made sense but uh but yeah
until it was a year ago that's when
everything kind of not everything kind
of switched but that's when i started
loosening up the pocketbooks a little
bit yeah
but prior to then i lived on
basically like 1500 a month what about
you smartest financial decision i've
ever made
law you shouldn't ask jack that the
obvious dogecoin
yeah what's the least amount of money
that you've lost in an investment i
don't i mean the
smartest financial decision i've ever
made yeah what's the biggest return
you've ever made the biggest return yeah
that's a good question i mean i
make dogecoin return i guess probably
the
biggest return would probably just be um
apple okay he's made
twenty dollars an apple no i i i don't
even know what i did i like
actually it would be dogecoin it would
actually be dogecoin yeah because i got
like 1700 percent
in dogecoin wow yeah
which is pretty amazing it was a hundred
dollars into 1700 yeah
my yeah if we're talking about roi like
that my best investment was actually
gamestop
for yeah and i was i was upset that i i
almost hit
a 2 000 return but i didn't it was like
the peak was like 1935 percent
and well i guess we could talk about it
because we're posting this in the future
but
i bought into gamestop around like 18
bucks
and sold half of it at 350
360 something yeah uh and that was this
i debated on that one i'm like i wanted
to hold it but then i was looking to
jack i'm like
how i shouldn't get greedy on this and
i'm like i could see that the
the attention on it was was it was like
waning down
and uh and i knew i was going to be
posting videos about it and i didn't
like i never wanted to be seen as trying
to like like drive up the cost i'm like
you know what let me i'll get rid of
half
uh so now i'm left with 50 shares and
i'm just i'm
holding those 50 shares so whatever
happens happens but
that's my that's my tribute to wall
street bed i'm just going to keep that i
got one share as a tribute as well there
we go two days ago nice
after it was already at like three
hundred bucks i was like not first
you're on the game you got your skin in
the game not for
financial gain but it's for more first
statement yeah yeah cool
so after some thinking i i would also
agree with graham my smartest financial
decision is uh living
below my means as well yeah graham knows
i'm frugal as well
jack needs to keep that i'm worried with
jack now that we'll be
i'm telling you funny enough i'm telling
jack to like get a roll he's telling me
to buy a roll but jack wants a tesla
tesla wait
how how are i guess a rolex is not a
depreciating no it's not at all
he's gonna get a wholesale cost
submariner
ask him how good of a deal that it's
like he's getting this watch 20
under market and i guarantee to him that
i would buy the watch back
i'm locking any point instantly whenever
he needs the money i'm locking up like a
lot of
assets that's the way that i don't like
to you know what i mean because it's
going up in value
that watch is going up it's like you
make it into as soon as i put a down
payment on a house
i'm done like my my finances are toast i
have
nothing after i didn't sell the wine so
and i'll buy it
okay all right fine you got me fine yeah
but i would say yes beneath my means but
also
i've been wanting to ask this question
this whole podcast what is the most
uncomfortable thing you have ever done
wow i'm sure
you've gotten that one let me guess a
million times oh yeah definitely yeah
like the go-to
i just i did the craziest thing you've
done no that was craziest but the most
like what
were you you were like oh this is like
odd or uncomfortable
i would say the two days that i spent on
the streets of l.a with nothing
wow yeah so that was i don't want to say
it was like
became homeless in l.a because i don't i
don't think there's anything i can do
that can simulate homelessness can you
see me the feeling of
not knowing when or where i can go back
to safety and
comfort but so i approached it through
the
stoic philosophy of um they have a
specific practice called negative
visualization which is
you living for a day or two of your year
assuming that the worst happened
uh and kind of like just going about
your day
assuming that and living life as if
you're responding to the worst
so for me that was you know losing all
my privileges including being able to be
presentable being able to go up to
people and express myself and ask for
what i want
so i couldn't even like be begging or
asking someone for
for help i fully took the 48 hours
i only had the face of my cellular apple
watch just in case
anything goes wrong i can make a call
from it but other than that i had
nothing i
ate from the trash that day it's two
days eight from the trash i walked from
beverly hills all the way to santa
monica and then to
play vista and then to the airport to
sleep on the second night because it was
the only like
public place where i wasn't gonna get
you know hassled for
for steven because everywhere el like
there's just so much i realized about
my life in la that i took for granted
and then for city that
by the day you see homelessness increase
uh
it just it was such a wake-up call why
couldn't you beg
because i felt like i felt like i i'm
very comfortable with that like i've
done
yeah i've done episodes where i would go
to a foreign country and
you know be on the street for 24 hours
and have the best
experience just by asking people so i
feel like
i i have that skill and and and the
whole point was to lose
all kinds of privilege so that was again
to
to be living in a city where
homelessness is so prominent and it's
something that
you i deal with every day i'm so happy
that i went through the experience
because it just
was such a prospective giver what did
you do all day
was there ever a point where it's like
you
i don't know like also wouldn't you have
gotten recognized
so i would i that's why i was like sort
of invisible i'm i wasn't even trying to
be in people's
like in people's face i was just like
walking resting during the day because
that night it was too cold and it was
really hard to sleep
so the whole time you're just focused on
survival
and also the other thing the reason this
was really hard is because you know i'm
so social i like
very connected i'm on my phone i you
know
social media all that and then all of a
sudden you literally have nothing
you the only thing you're left with is
your mind there's no there's nothing to
escape to
so i went from like the extreme contrast
of
having the best support system the best
friends and
like an amazing place to live and all
these things to
nothing and and that i think that
contrast was uh
was a really significant one in my
just yesterday career what did you eat i
ate one meal out of the whole foods
trash
it was the leftover of a drumstick and a
bunch of potatoes with hummus on them
that's it
it didn't taste very good i mean it was
it tasted it tasted decent you're
probably pretty hungry
yeah i it was and it was my only meal
for the 48 hours
what did you dress like i just wore i
wore black pants
a t-shirt and a jacket and a backpack
that had my point and shoot and that's
it
would you do that i would consider it
yeah i do i probably do that before i
would ever do uh
skydive wow
right that makes me even more committed
to be like i mean no i mean
rather no no i'm terrified of doing that
no no graham's terrified of staying at
home all day and lying in his bed
i can't do that well that's so scary you
brought a friend here yeah i did
cliff weisman my my greatest investment
ever
as just in terms of like my time with
do you want to oh you know what how are
you doing let's put them do you want to
just go right here
can we yeah because i think we screwed
over a little bit down yeah
if you scoot right here yeah this has
been my
my greatest investment both in terms of
time just the time that i've
invested spending with this man and in
terms of
uh money it's my biggest investment that
i've ever made and it's in his startup
because
i've i literally and again this is not
at all like
i'm not trying to do this like oh i'm
bringing him to promote what he's
building it's truly one of the
people that inspired me the most and i'm
i'm grateful to be introducing to you
because
yeah we saved this all for the podcast i
don't want to hear about it
until we're filming yeah so so we got
evidence
but what you know cliff you were saying
that ammar is leaving something out
oh yeah what did i leave you have a
major expense category that you're
forgetting which is amar
spends a unusually high amount of
personal his personal income on gifts
did he bring a gift today i'm the gift
today
but the first time one of the first time
we hung out we were playing paddle
tennis
so i would have been the partner that
was waiting um and there was a lady who
was like oh my god i love
your sweatshirt seek discomfort that's
so beautiful and she didn't know who
ammar was yeah
and she's waiting for the court and at
the end
he takes off a sweater he folds it and
he just gifts it to her
wow and i've seen this happen over and
over and over again
and he just has this ability to figure
out what a per would
make a person really delighted and he
just will go and get it
thank you man i it is true i i do spend
a lot of
well i like i like gifts you're welcome
back
yeah i'm looking at this like i i would
i would look like such a boss if i wore
something like could you like imagine me
walking around with this
because i you you see this and you're
like that's money that's
cool i like it all right it's it's got
to be like a small or like an extra
small for me done
all right but it's less material so it's
it should be easier to make
so this is your investment here yeah do
you want to store your story of how we
met
i'll tell the story okay so in october
of 2019
i got a text one random night being like
hey
there's someone that from a friend of
mine entrepreneur female entrepreneur
here in l.a she was like you know what
there's someone that i think you should
really really meet he reminds me a lot
of you
and then within five minutes i got
another text from another friend also a
female entrepreneur
being like you have to meet this guy
turns out that
the ladies man turns out
turns out that cliff was having dinner
with both of them
one of them goes to the bathroom and
then he
sat with the other one she goes you
should really meet amar
then the other one comes back from the
bathroom and goes demi you know who he
should meet he should be lamar so both
had
the same thought uh like separately
and then you know when both when both of
them texted me that i was like okay well
we gotta meet we gotta meet
this cliff guy and honestly i don't
think i ever told you this
i honestly thought he was too
unbelievable the first time i met him
that i'm like
ah is this another like ellie guy who's
just saying a bunch of a bunch of things
because he was so unbelievable i was
like there's no
way all these things he's built like all
these products in college and he's done
all the things that he's saying
that he does like he was just like yeah
usually i hear that it's red flags yeah
like
every time someone goes off about that
i'm like i did big time yeah big time so
for me i was like i was like well i
guess
and then and then i don't know what
ended up happening i think i
i what made you decide that it was not
i think i think i started i started
hearing about you from
other people and then having a lot of
these things be confirmed and i also
start following the trajectory of of
speechify like
all these things that that you're saying
that were that seemed so like out of the
out of your league at the time i was
just like holy bib by bit month by month
i'm seeing him
like get to these things that he said
that he wanted to get to and you know we
end up reconnected
reconnecting when he came back to la we
just like
ever since we became very very close and
uh uh very invested in what each other
doing i think
out of all the people that i've ever met
in my life there's no one that has like
shown such a deep understanding of what
is it that we're trying to do with the s
theory more than cliff
and i think in the same way with what
he's building as you know as someone
who's needed the tool that he's building
more than anyone growing up having
learning disability and
and having a really hard time just
dealing with academics and reading in
college
uh to me it was like i i was also very
invested in what he's building so
maybe you invested in clips i did invest
yeah yeah i did all right
it was big my biggest investment and you
know
proudest one yeah yeah i was just like
over 100k
no i wish he could i wish you'd you know
what yeah i swear i would do it if you
let me
right i was like you didn't want that
because that's fine there's a few people
that have gotten very mad at me for not
letting them invest
um well i want to win best no
let's hear the pitch i'll give you the
background
um speechify do i speak to you or do i
speak to you or which direction do you
want me to wherever you are no i agree
um so my story is pretty straightforward
i grew up in israel
and i moved to us when i was 13. and i'm
super dyslexic and i have a dd
so it's very hard for me to learn to
read like first second third fourth
grade like
i sucked at school and i have four
younger siblings who
are brilliant so i was just like
twiddling my thumbs not able to spell my
name and my brother is like building
websites and making iphone apps and my
sister like speaks seven languages and
i'm just like
eh but like i like i had an idea of the
person that i wanted to be
and that person one of the things they
should be able to do is read so i would
practice reading
and i would always fall asleep in the
book so then my dad started reading
books to me
and the first book he read to me was
harry potter and i loved it so much he
recorded himself in a cassette tape and
walk around the house listening
and then we moved to la when i was 13.
and i found an audiobook instead of
harry potter in english
and i listened to that 22 times in a row
to this day i have the first chapter
memorized
sadly i lost a british accent but it
made me fall in love with audiobooks so
i listen to
two books a week every week for the last
like 16 years
when i got to college i went to brown i
studied renewable energy engineering
i ended up building this app that let me
take pictures of physical books and it
would read them
and i could upload a pdf it would read i
could open a website it would read and i
build everything from like
3d printed skateboard breaks to payments
companies and apps and websites
um and at the end
i like really want to do my own thing i
didn't want to take a job i had like one
internship and i hated it
so i convinced two of my professors to
let me stay as a visiting scholar or
brown
basically i didn't pay tuition didn't do
homework lived on campus
eighth on meal plan and i just built
stuff and like guest talk classes
um and my philosophy is you want to be
the person that you needed most when you
were young
when i was young the thing i needed was
someone to read my books to me
and around that time there's a
subcategory of algorithms called deep
learning
and they're really good at optical
character recognition and text-to-speech
and translation and parsing and i tied
them all
into this hack that i built for myself
and it got
really popular at brown and then it
built this cult following of people like
me
who had dyslexia and add and low vision
and concussions and autism and second
language learners
um and then it got really popular with
normal people so now most of the users
are professionals or people in school
who use it because
they can listen and understand better
when they listen compared to when they
read
or they can listen faster than they can
read
or they do other things at the same time
and so then we built the iphone app for
it and then we built
the chrome work how does it work so for
the chrome extension
you can open a website and a little play
button appears
um so for example if you're reading
about robin hood and gamestop you're
like damn this is like a long
sec document play and it just starts to
play
and i like i read all every like
contract
i read and i listen at 700 words per
minute which is three and a half times
faster it's nuts when you walk into into
a room can i hear 700 words a minute
oh my god because i listen to all my
youtube videos two times speed and for
me sometimes that's like
not fast enough why did that one hold on
is it two times speed
i do audio books at 2.75 oh
wow yeah i'm super user here yeah that's
that's crazy need to get you on the
train no i
i mean i was telling you like i would
walk into i would walk into a room where
he's listening to something and i have
no idea what he's listening
and then i'm like there's no way you
just understood what was just said and
he would be like oh yeah this is what
happened and he would be listening to
our uh like a news article and then he
would tell me what happened in news
i'm like you can understand that
but the trick is just like you're
training yourself you're training
you're increasing your capacity bit by
bit to like listen
faster and faster and that was all right
let's let's hear it
so i listened to the teaching of writing
has gotten mixed together
is that like three x like what what
because i just i only know in like
youtube three x three x 3x what is the
normal
uh reading speed for like a normal
so the normal person when they read um
on a digital screen will read at 180
words per minute and if you read in a
physical book it'll be 200 words per
minute
and most people who use speechify off
the bat are listening at about 240 words
per minute because
most people like listen a little bit
faster than they read and if you
practice you can start listening really
fast
like you do 2.7 5x and audible so
when i learned english like i didn't
speak english when i was 13.
so i would listen to harry potter at
0.75 x speed and then little by little i
increased the speed
um and the key is that i was using i
started using it for everything
and speechify has an automatic speed
ramping algorithm inside of it so
every thousand words it'll boost you by
a little bit um and actually we're now
adding the ability to
increase youtube videos beyond 2x and
you can increase them by like .05 x
increments with a keyboard shortcut
so you can train it and so when i listen
it most of the time right i went in
fine um i i used to do you get texts do
they just read off like that
no and not yet honey we're building
honey dinner is ready please come home
it's 9 p.m let's pack your curfew please
come thank you
love mom um
but um what used to happen is i used to
sneak into conferences for kids with
dyslexia
and when the keynote speaker was
finished speaking i jump on the stage
and i'd plug in my computer i had a demo
and then like principals would offer to
fly me out to the school to teach the
kids how to use speechify
and i'd come in and kids would listen to
2 40 and i'd come in a couple of months
later
and the kids are now listening at like
350 400. and i come a couple months
later and they're now listening to
600 700. and the principles would go
yeah um
this is crazy because like this kid was
getting d's and f's
and what we realized is the speed of the
listening
needs to match the speed at which their
mind is working and that helps them
because
if you were to be forced to watch a
youtube video at 0.5 speed even though
you like the channel
you leave because it's so boring and for
most people their reading speed
is is not at the same pace as their
brain works like most 19 year olds today
they grew up on youtube and instagram
and tick tock and they move really fast
in their brain
but the information intake is too slow
and so so i listen i'll listen at 700
which is three and a half times faster
and i'm number like there's a
leaderboard
a number like 2500 um in the list like a
lot of people listen
way faster than i how do you prove that
do you actually understand
how do you know i could just listen at
four times speed and then call myself
a second ago yeah yeah um it was talking
about the literature
in england and how uh even the writer of
moby dick would not be interested
to read some of that material um yeah
but you memorize yeah i'm sure you've
listened to any article you want graham
yeah i've literally yeah
yeah like i've tested that okay
and i mean right you listen to 2.7 yeah
i couldn't understand that
no no but you listen to audio oh yeah
2.7 x speed um
most people when you give them those
audio books won't be able to listen to
them and you practice over time right
yeah so what did you listen when you
start started listening to audible
probably 2x
2x and you built up to 2.7 over time and
you watched youtube videos off
everything 2x yeah by default yep
um if you so here's the crazy part my
dad
used to hate it when i would listen fast
amar hates it when i
used to hate it but it was fast too um
and
um he couldn't stand it if i would watch
a video at 2x speed
and now he watches all his videos at 2x
speed he's 60 years old
and he uses speechify for everything now
okay and it's just a matter of practice
so
you know roger bannister ran the four
minute mile
and then everybody ran a four minute
mile that year it's just the type of
thing where like
you start at first grade and
and you're supposed to take like 10
years to become a fast reader
with high comprehension and we've been
reading for thousands of years but we've
been listening for millions of years
but to answer your previous question the
way that it works is on chrome you just
click play and it starts to read you
no matter what it is on ios you take a
picture of a book or you send an
article from chrome um or you upload a
pdf and it reads
now my thinking is on websites sometimes
there's so much just noise that's on
there you don't want to read
necessarily like who the article is
buying you got ads how does it
differentiate the actual
content create a question smart question
so
um when i first built it right it was
optimized for pdfs and for books where i
could take a picture with my phone it
would read the book
and i tried seven iterations of the
chrome extension before i succeeded in
building a parser that was good enough
to automatically skip over most of the
ads and so if you click play it'll just
it it knows just from training and for
like
we just like went to all the most
popular websites and adjusted it
and wrote macros for it to skip the
stuff that's irrelevant
um and then you can also like pick the
section that you want highlighted
and playing so for example 30 of the
uses in chrome are inside of
google docs and gmail and we just build
like a play button into gmail if you
click play
it plays and one of the cool things is
we were talking about like how i met mmr
all of our team are people who i met
either they found like stuff that i
wrote on medium or
wherever or people introduced us so
we're like 25 people um
and they're they're all folks who ended
up using it in the same way
um from from all over the world who work
in it with us
and they just like keep coming up with
ideas of how to make the product better
how do you come up with the voices how
do you keep improving those to make it
sound realistic
so today i had a meeting with uh morgan
friedman's
agent to try and get morgan's voice how
much to zach didn't he do he did a lot
he did a gps a long time ago i don't
think it was waze
he did one of the old ones back in like
this this must have been 2006 or seven
back when gps is first started being
like i used to garmin remember those the
garmin gps's
there was like a morgan freeman how much
is that like it's got to be like 10
million bucks 20. no
not 10 million no no it's expensive but
it's not that expensive really
he's actually you know he's had he has
already
other celebrities on like a celebrity
voices as a part of speechify
trevor noah did they just read the
entire dictionary
so here's what we do yeah i i've seen
how they do this it's so interesting you
explain it uh i was actually in gwyneth
paltrow's house um
last week and i just recorded her
reading a bunch of stuff for the app so
we can make her voice
um it used to be the text-to-speech was
what was it was made with the thing
called concatenative text-to-speech
they'd copy and paste speech utterances
together and i am a computer like i talk
to you
then deep learning came around um i
don't know if you ever saw like right
the
computer that beat the best world player
and go etc
and so it builds the sound wave from the
ground up
and so then you have like this corpus
this engine that's really really good at
reading but it's like
kind of unisex engine and then let's say
you want trevor noah's voice so you
pepper in the south african accent
and all i need is like a couple hours of
audio
at this point we've gotten it down to i
need 40 minutes and boom it sounds like
the native speaker david adam barrow do
you guys know yeah
it's just voices discovery
yeah okay oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it
sounds good this
is the exactly yeah and it's crazy when
you actually listen to it because
i think his intonations lend themselves
to to
work well in like a computer-generated
voice yeah
it's so good like you actually it
actually feels like david adam boris is
reading your book
i want gilbert godfreed that's who i
want all right you know what i like the
request
what's really i got the dictionary
you yeah yeah what's really cool is is
that you know in speechify you can
you know at some point you'll be able to
just record if your mom's voice is one
that you like is really soothing to you
that then you can that's crazy i would
love that just a voice of a loved one
imagine that as a christmas gift
like you just talk for 40 minutes and
then whatever you want is in
that person's voice so two things that
we're doing that would live on forever
is um we're going to release probably
later this year um
you'll be able to upload anyone's voice
um
and if i send amara text message and he
clicks play it'll play in my voice
or my mom text messages
and so every contact in your address
book has a speechify voice associated
with it but the other cool thing is
exactly what you're saying memorialized
voices
so if you have loved ones that are going
to pass you better make sure that you
upload their voice to speechify because
they might pass but
their voice can stay forever i think
everyone would do just based on that
like everybody like you hit the age of i
don't know 70 and you
just automatically will do this how do
you prevent copycats because it sounds
like once you get the
the template and the framework anybody
would be able to go and just kind of
make
something similar it's v so okay
this is a question i'm gonna bounce back
to you the trick with
building companies that are like fast
growth startups
um is it's all about the company the
team um
and so we build at such a fast rate
um that it's very very difficult to keep
up so that's number one that's the most
important part and then the second i
want to ask amar why he decided to
invest in speechify and why really all
yes theory has ended up investing with
us uh because i'm sure that's the reason
the second reason is the ux is really
good it's just like very very easy to
use
and you end up with the data mode
because once you upload right all the
articles
have you ever used pocket no so the
problem with pocket is a lot of people
love using pocket but you never actually
read the material
with speechify let's say you have 25
tabs open it goes oh 18 of your tabs are
long form content would you like to
collapse them into a folder on your
iphone and if you go around a walk or
drive you can just click play and listen
where you stop and you're like yeah
that'll be great
so then all the material you want to
listen it's like it's already there it's
like this expensive switching costs
uh so a lot of the voice stuff is
proprietary for example if you get the
agreement with morgan freedman that's it
like there's an exclusive agreement with
margaret friedman you can't have his
voice elsewhere
how is that so but doesn't he already
have his voice out
out there like with ringtones and yeah
voicemails the exclusive is like you
can't lend your voice to another
text-to-speech application that reads
pdf and use
so yeah you can pretty specific yeah and
it's like it's dynamically generated so
the cool part is
right um anything you want to read about
finance anything you read and you're
like
masters in medicine anything you're
reading for your for your job my emails
uh it dynamically generates everything i
mentioned my voice
like people could pay like 10 bucks just
reread a book in my voice
that's not hard to do i would love that
we're doing a partnership with a couple
of youtubers right now
um where we're making their voice
thomas's voice is going to be
yeah and then uh and then and then yeah
you can promote your your
your speech link and if someone buys
feature from your channel they can hear
what's gonna happen people could easily
just create like a fake web page where i
say something i didn't say
and then play it back be like hidden
audio grim admits to
something you know what you do here's
the trick is you have a high frequency
tone that's inside that you can't remove
so you can always prove that it wasn't
you oh that's good how many users do you
have
um many many many millions so speechify
has been like the number one app
in the magazine newspapers category on
apple for the last like 10 months above
the new york times and wall street
journal
um so it started with like very few and
then it just grew a lot and why the
investment
with this guy yeah just in general
because i i love him and i want him to
succeed as we continue to grow and he
also is one of the best product thinkers
i know
do you know what can you say like what
the valuation is right now or like
you can't say that okay have you gotten
buyout offers a lot yeah
exceeding like 50 60
a lot like most companies that you can
think of so like
right among our investors um
the founder of robinhood vlad yeah um
charles schwab uh gary cohen um
the founders of of grammarly of audible
um
of um who else brex plaid
like most really fast growing startups
um
and for the most part what we've done is
like we try to dodge like the bigger vcs
and take it
money from like founders who've built
stuff uh because they're other people
who are actually super useful because
they can like
give you the advice that's valuable and
i i don't know even if
if you're going to be saying that it's
it's not it's not a cheap
cert like product it's it's 140 bucks
and you pay it
right 140 and you pay it right away like
after a week of using it
so for him to have millions of users
that actually made the financial
decision to pay 140 bucks
that means something wow so it's free to
download free to use for a week and then
it's a hundred and forty dollars to try
to
description service the subscription
service you pay after the 12 months
so just to be clear there's many
millions who are free users
oh i see and then there's yeah a lot a
lot who are also paying users
um and and the differences in the
quality of the voices so you can have
voices that are
lower quality and then you can have
really nice voices um
um do you put your voice on there no you
got a pretty nice voice
thank you very much uh later if you
have an audience that likes your voice
um all i need is like an hour of your
audio
and then i can put your voice on
speechify and then if anybody comes from
your links and buy a speechify then you
get
a kind of thing people say of an
annoying voice
[Music]
i get caught i hate your voice graham
your voice is heard
but some people like your voice a few
people do weirdos
psychos like mine so so amar to answer
graham's more important question why did
you end up investing in speechify
the money no i mean because i it was
truly the product that i
would have wanted to use the most it was
the product that i wanted to build the
most that in 2015 i found a piece of
paper
that i actually sent them a photo of
when i was doing brainstorming on my
tech startup building at the time and it
was like one random night where i just
wrote
on the side of like basically like the
idea for not
speechify but something something very
very similar like i want something to
achieve the same functionality because
i couldn't think of a product that i
would use more given that
i'm also dyslexic very adhd
always had a hard time just like
focusing and and reading and consuming
knowledge in that way
and it's prevented me from i mean now
like i use audible to listen to books
but
you know anything that doesn't have a
real human listening to that's kind of
it rules it out from the things that i
would read or not but now just being
able to literally like
if i'm given a piece of paper and i can
just take a photo of it and have it be
read to me
that's that's pretty life-changing for
you know someone
someone like me and and and again for
someone else who speaks speaks english
as a second language
i see how this can be like a game
changer for people to like learn
languages and
you know what opened up the whole world
to me is the fact that i spoke english
it's literally it comes down to the fact
that i just was able to speak english
because you know it's like otherwise i'm
my knowledge is just limited to
what is in arabic and what's in arabic
can just be
you know a specific perspective that
might not necessarily be
the perspective that i want of the world
so
it to me it was like more of like a like
an emotional decision i was like i
i want to see every person using this
and i want to use my platform to be able
to bring it to every person that could
potentially benefit from from that
product yeah do you do other languages
it works in all languages it also does
auto translation between like okay
is there a feature to help kids learn
how to read great question
so there's a feature called automatic
speed ramping that helps you improve
your listening speed over time
there's a feature that we're going to
release later called the language
learning algorithm
and so it works in two ways the first
one is when i learned english
i didn't i didn't speak english but i
knew what like harry potter was and
hogwarts and
homora so i could like understand the
context of harry potter
um and so you start where the 500 most
commonly used words
are spoken to you dynamically in the
language that you want to learn
and then as you improve more and more of
the words happen in the other language
so let's say i want to read portuguese
and if i get to a certain level
i can just take things that are in
portuguese and listen to them but the
really difficult vocab words are
dynamically read in english and as i
improve it just
increases the difficulty rate and it's
across everything you want to consume
you know what would make a ton of money
man um
is something where you could take a
picture and it translates it to your
language
like it was already yeah really that's
okay that's what i would love to
translate do that with pictures really
but but they don't know anyway
like you could take a picture of a sign
it'll read the sign right with speechify
you could just like
i could i've done this in the past i'll
take a book in japanese i'll scan the
first chapter and then i'll say
translate to english and then just read
the book in english
and the thing about the way speechify
converts text to speech is that
at some point this deep learning
this the machine learning is gonna be
able to
take an article that's maybe written for
college uh
college-level reading and it can give it
back to you in like 10th grade
because that's cool it's literally it
has synthesized everything and it
understands exactly what the article is
trying to say that
it can give it to you and then i that's
also like i see that being such a game
changer
for lang for people who are learning how
to for learning new languages
just the overarching computer science
behind it is like people think about ai
as like
take over the world like that's not
what's going to happen in the next like
10 years
um the way that ai is really interesting
is ai is just computer that teaches
itself
and it's a system for learning and
what's really interesting today is
narrow ai the application in ai in
narrow fields for example
the optical character recognition of
taking a picture of this can and have it
turn into digital text the um
data building of the sound wave so it
can speak the ability to
dynamically do natural language
processing to summarize something
in a way where i can rewrite the
sentences from scratch so it's a
100-page article turns into a five-page
document that's like accurately
summarized and that's a lot of the stuff
that we do
what's your end goal with it are you
going to sell it off good
no um we've had so many snacks
at this point okay um so
the great thing about speechify is
number one
like when i graduated college i could
have gone and like just chilled on a
beach somewhere because i had like the
kind of news companies
um but the goal was if i was a
billionaire right now what would i want
to do with my life
and my answer was i want to solve
dyslexia and i got very very lucky that
schwab
saw a video of speechify early and sent
me a message and we ended up meeting and
he ended up being one of the first
investors
um and
if i was a billionaire what i would want
to do is go work on that so
it doesn't matter who you are where you
are i want to make sure that reading is
never a barrier for learning
to anyone and the thing that really
strikes me is odd
so for example india is our fourth
fastest growing country right now
and africa as a continent also grows
really really fast so i just had a call
with a woman from zambia
and she's doing grad school in nursing
and
um she like reads decent but like not
fast enough to be able to
have an easy time doing a masters in
nursing so she uses speechify for
everything
and so it started off as an
accessibility tool then it turned into a
productivity tool and now it's becoming
a literacy tool
and so my goal is i should be able to go
into any office any school and say hi my
name is cliff i have dyslexia and
um anyone here has this here too cool
anyone heard about speechify sweet who
uses speechify
and all the handshakes stay up but the
long term vision is not just having this
like utility that's a great consumer
subscription
it's you get to the point where people
are consuming trillions of words per
week on your platform
and you're able to start building an
audio profile to recommend to people
based on their completion rate not the
clicking of the title um the things that
are most relevant to them
um because there's just the world was
desked up first
and then move to mobile first so like so
you would create like a youtube
algorithm where it's like oh you like
reading
investing articles well let me suggest
these other investing articles that's
right you know we make a lot of money
i just think about everything that would
make money get this really quick yeah
throw in an
ad right in the middle of it like right
at the peak interest and then it's like
by the way go go and use weeble where
you can get four free stocks down below
in the description click the link and
like a link comes up on the app and you
click the link you get
four free stocks down below in the
description when you deposit a hundred
dollars on the platform
um yeah um
the biggest thing is that you know how
do you consume
yeah the world it's either through your
browser yeah youtube and reddit exactly
listening at this point and watching uh
listen listen youtube
uh reddit reading yep yeah but like in
terms of
your access to the internet you're
accessing that either through apps
that are trying to get you to stay on
youtube
yeah on the side of your device on your
device for as long as possible so that
you can continue consuming
the world through them yeah or your
browser
uh because it's how you you go on to any
website
imagine the point where you're able to
consume just
just the whole the whole internet by
listening
and for that pipe that that controls
that being speechify
all of a sudden you have you know
exactly what people are reading
up to what point they're reading it you
know exactly who are the most prominent
writers
uh on the rise because people are having
more completion rates for their articles
past anyone else like all of a sudden
you're just able to identify so much
about what people
are genuinely interested in because
reading is such
a specific meticulous task it's not just
like you can't just passively
you can't passively read but it's
different than passively watching
something or like scrolling right
through it
but oddly enough for reading and stuff
like that i i guess for me it's more so
spotify or i'll listen to a podcast yeah
and that'll be like my version of
reading and just listen to it so yours
is basically just doing that but taking
the text
that's already up there yeah so for me
um
i love books hate reading but love books
because they're really dense sources of
information um
but there's books that i just i can't
they don't have an audio book right or a
wikipedia article or
a long reddit thread um
and there's like so much good text
that exists on the internet like i want
to read i remember when i was young
i wanted to know how planes fly and i
would go to the wikipedia article and
read the first sentence i get a little
bit bored second sentence i'd quit
but now like i just like i walk around
and i listen to it yeah um and so if you
are an auditory learner
and you use audible or you use podcasts
or you use youtube
and you assign a textbook for school it
makes it just easy to consume same thing
for any other source of medium so it's
not to replace them
but it's to allow you to add text do you
worry about let's say i write this
really amazing article
and it's mine but then i'm pissed that
like wait a second everyone's consuming
it through your app and you're making
money from my thing and people aren't
going to my website on that
you ever concerned about that so the
trick there is you do attribution for
those creators and you make sure that
um it links back to their article b if
you
run ads like they get credit for it in
the same way that youtube does
how would how would that work because
then wouldn't everyone have to sign up
for ads like let's say i write a medium
article for free
throw it up there and then you're
running ads but i don't know
that you're making money on that yes so
right now we don't run ads on speeches
we don't intend to for a very long time
because the subscription covers
everything and
there's also like mostly users use the
free version
um it's only the power users that
subscribe and for them like it saves you
like five hours per week so it's a
no-brainer um one thing that we're doing
now is if you are
a creator let's say you had a blog and
you wrote your blog somewhere
you can include a speech the link to
speechify and if someone clicks on your
link and
and listens then you you get paid by
speech about you wouldn't need to
register in the same way that you would
need to register for
for youtube um but yeah like the way
or protecting content is really
important so right now within speechify
there is no way for you to discover
content inside of the app
anything that you read you need to find
somewhere else right so
you take that book and you scan it you
go to your website and you click read on
inside your browser 50 of the time
people have the phone open
when they're listening so they look and
listen at the same time which increases
retention and comprehension
um but you can then also take a walk if
you want
later we'll need to cross the bridge
that you're describing cool
cool i like it thanks thanks for the
pitch i appreciate it
shark thank you i'm gonna use it i like
it i'll throw in
10 grand today but 5 million
valuation today cash cash
there you go you making money did your
valuation go up i'll i'll
i'll evaluation i'll flip it on i'll pay
you 10k
and and and you uh promote speech refine
will give you a cut of the number of
people who download it
could that be a welcome our video
sponsor today
thank you guys so much i really
appreciate this this has been probably
it's so much fun just being able to chat
it's just a tr first it's a trip meeting
like i keep looking over and like
i can't believe it seriously because i
remember watching you guys like now
six years ago uh yeah so it's just it's
wild
thank you so much what an honor thank
you crazy i definitely thank you for the
advice and
i hope to stay in contact and just like
continue consulting with you on
yeah you know how how i can live a
financially healthier life and
and i think it's i was just talking to
matt about this it's very much within
you know our interest to have the topic
of like
discomfort and finance be one that we
you know discuss more in 2021 so
i hope that we find nice to collaborate
whatever you need like you could just
shoot me a text perfect i don't care any
time
perfect whatever i can help with amazing
cliff amazing good pitch
thank you appreciate it cool so with
that said you guys thank you so much for
watching really appreciate it we'll link
to all the information down below in the
description
oh you got to say to like the video you
have to speak like guys please destroy
the like button
like button alright guys please destroy
the like button so that the algorithm
can
recommend this video uh make sure you
leave a comment let us know what really
stuck out to you in this episode
and we'll see you for the 40th episode
not me but these guys
yeah right after you get your four free
stocks four free stocks for the 40th
episode down below in the description
it's only free it's like basically free
money
so if you want free money you may as
well just go and do that so
thanks guys until next time cheers
okay just say um just let's just say uh
welcome back to the 38th
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
okay
my name is ammar and so far we have made
and then just say the amount of money
which i'll pull up right here
that we have made so far okay on the
podcast 36
454. okay cool got it
so what's up everybody i'm ma
i am ammar from yes theory and we are on
the 39th
episode ever off of the iced coffee
hour what is it iced coffee iced coffee
yeah okay yeah you just wing it so far
the podcast is made
thirty six four five four yeah and then
say that yeah yeah yeah
cool uh into which one probably this uh
that big one right there that's just
onions that's your angle